Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Japanese comedy drama film called
“When I Get Home, My Wife Always Pretends to Be
Dead.” Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
Jun Kagami is a regular office worker living in
Tokyo with his wife Chie Kagami. Jun believes
that if a marriage lasts for more than three
years without much hardship, the couple is
made for each other. His first marriage ended
after three years, so before marrying Chie,
the two had made an agreement to renew their
marriage contract after their third anniversary.
If they feel like they can no longer be together,
they will simply walk out of each other’s life.
Currently, the pair’s third marriage anniversary
is approaching and Jun is nervous about how their
future will play out. While thinking about
such things, he returns home from work.
He rings the doorbell but no one answers. It is
quite unusual because Chie always welcomes him at
the door. Jun uses the spare key to get inside and
is met with a horrifying sight. Chie is lying limp
on the floor with blood dripping from her mouth.
He falls beside her and tries to wake her up but
to no avail. In the moment of panic, Jun remembers
all the good times he has shared with his wife.
On their wedding day, she had asked him to die
before her so she wouldn’t have to live without
him. A few seconds later, Jun comes back to his
senses and composes himself. He tries calling
for an ambulance when suddenly, Chie grabs his
legs, revealing that it was just a prank.
As Jun looks at her in shock, she asks him if he
is surprised and giggles. When he doesn’t reply
she simply asks him to come to the kitchen for
dinner. After Jun has come out of his shocked
state, he jokes about Chie using ketchup as
fake blood. The couple laughs as Chie mocks
Jun’s reaction to the prank. For the rest of
the dinner, their mood is happy and lightened.
The following morning, Chie asks for a kiss before
Jun leaves for work. He tells her they are not
newlyweds anymore so it is just cringe. Chie,
however, doesn’t share his views. She hugs him
tightly claiming that they never know what will
happen during the day so this might be their
last goodbye. On his way out, Jun drops off the
grange bag into the bins. A cleaning lady goes
through them and sees the bloodied clothes
from yesterday. She starts to believe Jun
is doing something sketchy in his apartment.
In the office, Jun tells his co-worker Sano
about the prank Chie pulled on him yesterday. Sano
compliments Chie for putting effort to be funny
and wishes his wife was less serious. Jun thinks
that Chie is testing to see if he still loves her
so it would be easier to decide if she wants
to stay with him even after three years.
Later, in the evening, Chie is cooking
dinner when she gets a text from Jun
saying that he is returning home.
She smiles mischievously at the text,
ready for her next prank. Some minutes later, Jun
walks in and sees his wife lying on the floor with
her head inside a realistic alligator’s mouth.
She is pretending to be eaten by the animal. Jun
plays along and pulls her out of its mouth to
“save” her. She dramatically thanks her husband
for saving her life and says that they should eat
dinner now. Following that, Chie continues to play
dead every day, getting more creative with each
prank. One day, she pretends to be a maid who died
after being caught in a conflict. Following that,
she is a trapped soldier shot by the enemies. But
the one that impresses Jun the most is when she
pretends to be shot by an arrow through her head.
He compliments the creativeness, although he is
getting more and more bothered by the pranks as
time passes. Jun cannot decipher why she is doing
them, and with the third anniversary approaching,
it worries him even more. One day, he is
dumping the garbage again, which now mostly
contains props that Chie uses to pretend to be
dead. The cleaning lady goes through the bag
and finds a bloodied knife. She makes a scene
in front of everyone and calms down only when
Jun explains to her that the blood is ketchup.
He again expresses his uneasiness to his coworker
Sano who suggests he send Chie to her parent’s
home for a few days. As they talk, Jun begins to
tell him how he first met Chie and got to know
her. He was in Shizuoka for a business meeting
but he missed his bus back home. Chie saw him
running behind it and invited him to her father’s
restaurant. She was a pretty young girl but her
cheerful personality is what caught Jun’s eyes.
Her mother had passed away when she was
only five but she never let her sadness show
in front of people. Before leaving, she had told
him her wish was to eat a dessert from Mont Saint
Clair in Tokyo and he invited her to the city
sometime later. Sano is pleasantly surprised by
the unique love story. That day, Jun returns home
to see Chie has turned herself into an old soldier
from the medieval period who died in the war. She
has used several arrows because Jun had praised
her the last time. He plays along and pretends
to be sad about her death. But he doesn’t have
to pretend anymore when he sees the price tag
on the costume she is wearing. The next day,
he tells Sano that he is going to play along with
the pranks to see if she will stop doing them.
Hence, when he returns home and sees her being
abducted by fake aliens, he puts on the best
performance of his life and fights them.
However, it doesn’t stop Chie, instead,
she prepares him an elaborate skit, asking him
to perform better. One time, she pretends to be a
dead vampire who has to be revived by pulling out
the dagger on her chest. Jun does as the skit says
and gets bitten by her in the process. Following
that, she pretends to be Juliet who needs Romeo’s
help to be revived from the dead. Similar to the
last time, Jun acts like he is mourning and brings
her back to life. At work, he cannot focus
anymore and is almost scared to return home.
Sano sympathizes with his work friend. To
make him avoid the pranks for just a day,
he invites the couple to dinner with his wife.
They all meet at a restaurant at the end of the
day. Sano’s wife Yumiko also joins them. While
talking, Chie is asked why she decided to marry
Jun. A flashback shows us that after meeting at
the restaurant, the pair met in Tokyo as well. Jun
takes Chie to the cafe she always wanted to visit.
While walking through the streets of Tokyo, Chie
runs after a street vendor that sells her favorite
wafer cake. Jun bolts behind her and finally gets
to the vendor. Since he has only one cake left,
they share it. Chie gives him the bigger piece,
but Jun asks her to have the bigger one.
This was when she fell in love with him.
Back in the present, while returning home, Jan
falls in love with his wife again. They look at
the moon and appreciate its beauty together.
One day, on his way home, Jun notices an
advertisement for a vacancy at a local laundry
place. He thinks if Chie starts working,
she will have less time for the pranks so
he brings the paper home. She welcomes him
dressed as an Egyptian princess inside a coffin.
After the dramatic encounter, they simply walk
to the kitchen for dinner. Jun tells her
about the vacancy and urges her to apply.
Chie is skeptical at first but she agrees to
do it anyway. Starting the next day, she works
at the laundry shop owned by an old man. Yet,
it doesn’t stop her from executing the pranks.
She pretends to be killed by a bank robber that
evening. Having had enough, Jun tells her that
he is tired of seeing her play dead. The next day,
Chie goes on a date with Sano’s wife Yumiko, and
finds out she has been trying to get pregnant for
six years but hasn’t been successful. The couple’s
relationship is rocky because of this but Chie’s
kind words make Yumiko feel better. Jun brings his
wife flowers and her favorite cake but when he
enters the apartment, he sees her pretending to
be a ghost rising from her grave. Since he asked
her to not play dead, she pretended to be a ghost
who is already dead. She hugs him for the cake
and cooks him something good for dinner. On the
weekend, she pretends to be a robot but Jun
forcefully makes her take the mask off.
Following that, he notices a letter from his
former wife asking him to meet her someday.
The pair invites Sano and his wife to dinner one
day. Yumiko notices the alligator toy in the room
and is fascinated by it. It turns out that she
is very much into alligators which surprises
even her husband. Everything goes well until
Sano mentions that men need time off from their
wives. This upsets Yumiko and she gets into an
argument with Sano. To make her feel better,
Chie offers her the alligator if she wins a match
of arm wrestling against her. Yumiko wins because
she used to train at karate. She happily takes the
alligator home. Sano feels bad because he didn’t
know his wife’s interests even after being married
for six years. The following day, Jun comes home
to see Chie has turned herself into a person from
2050. For the first few minutes, he plays along
and asks her questions about the future. But
then, he inquires what he has to do for her
to stop pulling these pranks. Chie goes silent
and starts to calculate the average number of
days they will spend together in the future. Even
when he persists, she doesn’t answer his question.
Some days later, Yumiko tells Chie that she and
Sano have decided to separate. She thanks Chie
for making her feel appreciated. Because of her,
the couple was able to talk about their feelings
to each other. Somewhere else, Jun and Sano go
to a restaurant to talk about the matter.
Sano claims that the divorce is a good decision
for both of them because Yumiko deserves a more
attentive partner. Jun also reveals that
his ex-wife once disappeared for two weeks
and came back saying she wanted a divorce.
By the end of the night, he is very drunk
so Chie picks him up. The following day,
they get the news about Chie’s father being
in the hospital because of a heart attack. They
quickly rush to her hometown and meet her father
who has thankfully been saved. Chie meets him but
cannot control her tears afterward. When she is
not in the room, her father tells Jun that she
hasn’t cried since her mother’s death. He also
mentions that one night after her mother died,
Chie saw him crying while looking at her picture.
Starting the next day, she began to hide
around the house when he returned from work.
At first, her father thought it was
troublesome and weird but as time went on,
the simple activity of her hiding made him get
over his wife’s death because he was occupied. Jun
realizes that he also has been more involved in
their relationship since she started to play dead.
He registers that her pranks are not a result of
her being unsatisfied but she just wanted to feel
closer to him and keep him entertained. Later,
the two go to the park where Jun proposed to her.
They spend the rest of their day talking
to each other about different things.
The pair returns to Tokyo after a few days. Chie
comes back home after work to see Jun lying on the
floor with blood spewing from his mouth. She
freaks out and tries to wake him up but soon
realizes he is also pulling a prank. The movie
ends as Jun suggests they have dinner but Chie
is too mad at him for scaring her like that.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.